نحن نعلم كلابنا الكثير من الحيل
ولكننا الآن نتعلم واحدة منهم مع
بدء بحث جديد على لقاح جديد
مصنوع من عناصر كان العديد من الكلاب
موجودة بالفعل حوله ويستخدم بشكل
شائع في لقاح للكلاب
يقود البحث الدكتور بول سبيرمان  في
مستشفى سينسيناتي للأطفال على هذا
اللقاح الذي لا يحتوي على إبرة ، يكون
مختلفًا تمامًا عن لقاح mrna ، بمعنى
أن هذا ناقل فيروسي حي ولكنه غير ضار
نقوم بضخه في
الأنف يشبه لقاحات الأنف التقليدية
التي تم استخدامها
للإنفلونزا على مر السنين.  يستخدم أحدهم
فيروسًا حيًا ، وهو ناقل لم يتم استخدامه
في البشر ، لكن العديد من الأشخاص قد
اتصلوا به ، يعد فيروس piv5 نفسه أو
فيروس الأنفلونزا الفقرة من النوع 5 جزءًا من
لقاح السعال الذي يُعطى
للكلاب ويتعرض الأشخاص لذلك.
ونعلم أنهم يفعلون ذلك لأنه تم
تقييم ذلك وبقدر ما نعلم أنهم
لم تظهر عليهم أعراض أبدًا إلى جانب حقيقة
أنه لا يستخدم أي إبر يعتقد الباحثون أن
الميزة الرئيسية هي أنه يبني
الحماية في الأنف
والجهاز التنفسي العلوي حيث تهاجم فيروسات الطمع ،
لذلك نأمل أن يمنع هذا النوع من
اللقاح ، وهو لقاح داخل الأنف ، في
الواقع
من إصابة مجرى الهواء العلوي بالعدوى
وهو ما يحدث دائمًا قبل أن
تحصل على الجهاز التنفسي السفلي.
يتم إجراؤه في الأطفال
لشركة تسمى
scion vac ، ويسمى اللقاح cvxga1
ودراسة تأخذ صفحة من الجراء على
أمل إطلاق العنان لمراقب جديد للفيروسات